je parle
de ceux ci demandent qu'à dresse à la
russie les républiques populaires de
donetsk de lougansk demande de
reconnaître leurs sources
mais également la décision de la demande
sur ce même sujet
l'appel adressé aux présidents ou chefs
de d'état le reconnaître la souveraineté
et l'indépendance des républiques
populaires
et vladimir poutine dit qu'il prendra sa
décision aujourd'hui l'ukraine vient de
demander à une réunion d'urgence du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu bonjour
gulliver craque on vous retrouve en
direct de kiev cette reconnaissance
signoret telle la fin des accords de
minsk oui c'est vladimir poutine lui
même qui l'a dit il y a quelques jours
que reconnaître c'est soi-disant
république signalerait la fin des
accords de minsk donc cela ne fait pas
de secret alors vladimir poutine l'avait
utilisé comme argument contre l'idée de
reconnaître les soi-disant république
populaire de doigts donetsk est de loin
ce que mais aujourd'hui après cette mise
en scène de cette réunion du conseil de
sécurité il semblait beaucoup plus
ouverte à la question est donc la
question pour l'ukraine c est ce que
cela est une bonne chose ou non d'un
côté si cela veut dire la fin des impôts
de minsk cela veut dire la fin des
prétentions de la russie de contrôler
une partie de l'ukraine qui aurait une
certaine autonomie et qui pourraient
être utilisés pour
comme un outil d'influencé russe en
ukraine donc certains en ukraine
pourrait même se réjouir si le pays n'a
plus à remplir les conditions d apport
de minsk et agro 17 autonomie à ces
régions en les gardons dans l'ukraine
mais de l'autre côté ce qu'il ne faut
pas oublier c'est que pour le moment les
séparatistes soutenus par la russie
contrôlent seulement une partie des
régions qu'ils prétendent contrôler
selon les soi-disant constitution de
leur revue république autoproclamée
c'est l'intégralité des régions de
donetsk et de loin ce que qu'ils
devraient contrôler et beaucoup en
ukraine pense que la reconnaissance de
ces républiques par la russie serait le
prélude à une assist russ militaire
affiché à ces séparatistes pour partir à
la conquête du reste du territoire qu
ils prétendre être la leur merci pour
cet éclairage gulliver craag en direct
de kiev sur le